[Music]
guys I want to start tonight off by
saying something a little bit
controversial I hope you still like me
after this declarative statement
I hate chores there I said it
TBS executives picking up the red phone
like Holmes went rogue taking a stance
on chores meanwhile a bunch of
eight-year-olds are like finally a
monologue for us goddamn Caprice I hate
chores I seriously do all that scrubbing
scrubbing and rinsing and folding and
putting so much pudding I hate it I'm
not into it but I do them anyway why
because chores are a favor you do for
your future self does that make sense
it's a little bit like time travel past
Pete is helping out future Pete like
past Pete didn't want to identify the
mystery smell in the fridge but future
Pete sure is glad he did waking up in
the morning like open on the fridge like
huh path Peeta throughout my mound of
uncharred sauerkraut really cleared it
up in there thanks me I owe you one
that's what I'm saying washing a greasy
pan after dinner we all know that sucks
especially if you have if you're like me
and you don't have a dishwasher so what
I normally do is I put it in the sink
fill it with soap and water and let it
soak
which everyone does that and everyone
knows it does nothing it does nothing
letting it soak is code for watching
Netflix you there's no way that does
anything but Casspi doesn't do that
anymore he has to wash the pan why for a
future P do it for future P otherwise
future penis waking up the next morning
finding that old congealed food is now
just part of the pan
it's like garbage you might as well just
be like I'd rather throw this away then
clean it like I can't keep doing this
I've spent over $200 on pans just this
month at irresponsible it's a bad
feeling but you know it's a great
feeling yes you do waking up and seeing
a perfectly spotless pan that's like
you're your own Secret Santa past you
gave you a gift like how do you know how
do you know I like to clean pants
thank you pass P listen I know do your
chores is probably not what you plan on
hearing when you tune in to a late-night
show it's not really that exciting
you're much be cooler if I was like
brushing your teeth but here's why you
should take care of business
it feels great when you wake up and you
remember you brushed your teeth like a
big man you let them and they're smooth
not fuzzy like they're all wearing tiny
tooth sweaters that's not a good way to
start today be like alright I drank a
whole thing of triple sec and fell
asleep on my couch not good so do the
shitty thing now so you don't have to do
a shittier version of the shitty thing
later do it for future you future you
might be bringing a girl home you don't
want to bring them in underwear just
strewn everywhere got to move them off
the couch there's one on the lamb just
like sorry
my roommates kind of a dick just like I
thought you said you lived alone I do
[Applause]
[Music]